Alhamdulillah we finished
a pretty sizeable
portion
of
the chapters of fiqh. And most chap most
books of fiqh are structured in the way
that this book is.
Just happened to choose this book from a
number of possible choices because of
its concise
abridged formula
and that it mentions the evidences,
right? So, it'll mention the author will
mention the issue, the topic, the
ruling, and then the evidence. It's most
clearest, most authentic evidence, which
is what we need. This is what we need to
learn how to worship Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala.
Now,
we finished
the chapters regarding an-najasah.
We finished the chapters regarding
the various types of vessels, the
various types of water,
the various types of things that purify,
and we have finished the chapters
regarding wudu, and even the monolithic
wiping over the socks.
And so,
now the author
goes into the other
remaining types of purification.
Purification with the water
is two types,
wudu and ghusl, bathing. Now, he's
mentioned in wudu, we finished that.
Now, we're going to go into the chapter
regarding
al-ghusl, bathing.
And first, what we're going to start
with is what constitutes
bathing. What
what state of being must a person bathe
in order to get out of, right?
And so, there are a few things that
obligate
bathing.
And bathing
for the believer, and wudu for the
believer, is one of the most
prominent
hallmarks of a Muslim.
As a matter of fact, bathing from
janabah
is a hallmark of
all legislations that come from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Every
religion that has its roots in divine
revelation,
Christianity, Judaism,
there is the obligation of bathing from
janabah.
To the point that the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wa sallam says in one of the
wordings
of the narration in Sahih Muslim, we
know the narration of Omar,
a man came while we were sitting with
the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam,
shadidu sawad al sha'ar, shadidu bayad
al thiyab.
He had very black hair and very white
the narration of Jibril.
Well, when he asked him about al Islam,
akhbirni an al Islam,
in the wording of Sahih Muslim, he said,
[Arabic recitation]
In other wordings, he said more than
that.
He said,
is that you establish prayer and that
you bathe from janabah. And so he
mentioned bathing from al janabah as
being part of the hallmarks of what
differentiate a Muslim from a
non-Muslim.
So bathing is part of the sha'a'ir
of Islam. We prepare ourselves for Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in a number of ways.
And one of those ways is bathing.
We prepare ourselves for Jumu'. We
prepare ourselves
for after death. We prepare ourselves
before death.
What was one of the last things that the
prophet sal Allah alayhi wasallam did
before he died?
He bathed. Alayhi salat wasallam. What's
the first thing we do
to
our brother or our sister's body as soon
as they pass away? We bathe them.
Correct?
We bathe for Jumu'. We bathe for Eid.
We bathe after
you know, from al-janabah. This is part
of our
part of the ways that we
glorify Allah subhana wa ta'ala is that
we bathe. And so, it's very important
that we
perfect this great worship of
bathing. So, what are the states of
being that demand a person bathe? The
scholars the fuqaha, they would refer to
this as mujibat al-ghusl. Mujibat
al-ghusl.
Mujibat jam' mujiba.
[Arabic recitation]
hadha ta'nif li-ism fa'il al-wujub.
Ya'ni alladhi yujibu al-ghusl.
Ahwal idha kana fiha al-insan aw ashya
idha dhaharat aw halla waqtuh
fa-innahu yajibu alayhi wujuban an
yaghtasila.
An yaghtasila wa hadha min abrazi
sha'airi din Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
So, what are the things that necessitate
that a person bathe?
The author here, he mentions five. Five
things
in which five instances in which it is
obligatory for a person to bathe. Now, I
want before we get into these five
things, I want to mention something and
that is
that just because it is obligatory
doesn't mean that other acts of worship
are necessarily built upon that
obligation. So, for instance, he's going
to mention Jumu'.
That Jumu'
is a time that is obligatory upon the
believer to bathe. Why? Because the
prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam said,
"Ghusl al-Jumu' wajib."
we can't change his words. He said,
"Bathing for Jumu' is obligatory."
That's the narration.
A person may say, "Well,
how can we how can we harmonize that
with
the opinion of the majority of the
fuqaha including the companions
including Umar ibn al-Khattab and Uthman
ibn Affan radiyallahu anhum that Jumu'
is valid for someone who has not
bathed?" We say,
"Jumu''s validity
the salah of Jumu' is not its validity
is not built upon a person bathing. But
that doesn't mean meaning that
one of the conditions of Jumu' is that
a person bathe." No.
But that doesn't mean that it's not
obligatory cuz that's what the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam said.
And we will get into that inshallah
[Arabic recitation]
Al-janabah.
Or a person who is junub.
And Allah mentions al-janabah in the
Quran.
He says
Way akulu ta'ala.
Wa in kuntum junuban fa taharu.
And so al-janabah is a state of
impurity. It's a major hadath. Remember
the word we used hadath
for a person who needs wudu. That's
minor hadath.
How do we know it's minor? It is minor
hadath because a person need not
do the full bathing in order to to to
relieve it. A person must make wudu.
This is major hadath.
Major hadath means that a person, no
matter how much they wash or they cannot
be in a state of purity until they bathe
completely.
He says, "The first is the release
of sperm
or the release of sexual
secretions
that
only
come about by way of sexual climax.
This is
al-janabah.
Now, for men,
the meaning is very clear.
The Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
says in Sahih Muslim that water
is only necessitated by water. What does
he mean by that? Because in the Arabic
language, the
sperm,
the male sperm or the male semen is
referred to as water
in the Arabic language.
a man's water, meaning a man's sperm.
He says that water
is only obligated by water, meaning the
water of ghusl becomes obligatory
with the water of
a man's water. Now, a man or a woman,
they both have
what is referred to as water or sexual
secretions that are released at climax.
And the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam mentioned as much
when he was asked by
one of the
female companions in the narration of
Salamah, as we'll get to.
He was asked
if a person has a dream
of sexual activity and then they wake
up, do they have to make ghusl? And he
said,
"If the person finds that they have
secreted that water."
And this is for men and women, because
he responded to women and men. But it is
very different for men than it is for
women.
And we will get into the descriptions of
a many tomorrow, inshallah, and finish
this first part of
al-janabah of
[Arabic recitation]